[Music]
a Henderson mother is speaking out this
afternoon seeking your help her
firstborn son is struggling with
seizures and that caused the family dog
to become a service animal well today
she shares the struggle of caring for
her son and the financial burden to keep
her four-legged assistant by her side
I'm you know so grateful that I'm able
to be home with him but it's not the
situation that you envision being a
stay-at-home mom Alyssa fotenhauer says
her world changed when she had her first
baby Atlas a big blessing for her family
that she says quickly required all her
attention when Atlas began to have
seizures he initially started to have
like you know up to eight a day and then
a dozen and then 20 and then when it was
up to 40 a day I was like nope we can't
do this something is terribly wrong so
we've been to the ER a couple of times
we've been out of state several times
fortenhauer says doctors are still
looking to see what is triggering the
seizures which keeps this Mom very busy
to help care for the baby the family dog
CeCe was trained to become a service dog
she would help the stay-at-home mom when
Atlas would need special attention she's
seven but because she was already so
bonded and attuned an alert to him a
trainer did come over and was like we
can we can help you like we can really
get her to tune in we know a command
it's a we say go blue and she will run
right towards Atlas She lays down right
next to him it's called deep pressure
therapy while dad works full time she
says the cost to keep [ __ ] trained
became challenging with only one income
with no other option she turned to the
online community for help and the love
quickly began to pour in like whoa wait
a minute like there's people out there
like people are listening and people
share our story and that really has made
a huge huge difference
well mom says between the hospital and
other medical bills their debt is
growing now she decided to share her
story to inspire other families in
similar situations to not be ashamed and
ask for help if you would like to donate
please check our website 8newsnow.com